ذلك ينضموا الينا من واشنطن لاري كورب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السبق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي مرحبا
بك معنا السيد لاري كيف يمكن توصيف هذه
الضربه الامريكيه البريطانيه المشتركه على
اليمن اعتقد ان هذا يعتبر مؤشرا بالنسبه
الحوثيين ان السيل قد بلغ الزبا وبالتالي
فان لابد ان يتوقفوا عن منع السفن التي
تمر عبر البحر الاحمر استهداف الطائرات
التي جرت قبل اسبوع واعاقه الملاحه الامر
لا يتعلق فقط بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وانما كذلك المملكه المتحده نحن كنا هناك
مع دول مختلفه بما في ذلك دوله هنا في
المطقه الا وهي البحرين ما نقول هنا يجدر
بالحوثيين ان يتوقفوا والا فانه سيتم
المزيد والمزيد من الاستهداف ببلدهم طيب
هناك اشاره الى ان العمليه هي بالفعل
امريكيه وبريطانيا ولكن جاءت ايضا بدعم من
كل من استراليا كندا هولندا والبحرين وكنت
قد اشرت الى البحرين في حديثك في تقديرك
ما طبيعه الدعم الذي قدم من هذه
الدول اعتقد ان ربما قدموه هو انهم ساعدوا
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا بمعلومات
استخباراتيه بشان الاهداف وفي التاكد انه
عندما تتم عمليه الهجوم يتم التاكد انه لا
يتم استهداف السفن التجاريه والتي كانت
العمليات التي تقوم بها الجهات
منذ بدء العمليه في غزه هل تتوقع ردا من
قبل انصار الله الحوثيين على ما اقدمت
عليه الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا لا اتوقع ان يقوموا بالرد لانه
ليس لديهم قدرات ليفعلوا ما يودون القيام
به هم يعرفون ان الامر قد وصل الى ذروته
وبالتالي لابد ان يتوقف وايران ستخبرهم ان
يقوموا بذلك لان اخر شيء تريده ايران هي
المشاركه في مثل هذه الحرب اذا حتى الان
كان هناك وكلاء يقومون بذلك ولم تكن هناك
كلفه لكن هذه بدايه الكلفه وبالتالي
الحوثيون الذين عاشوا حربا اهليه وبالتالي
هذا سيقو قدرتهم في السيطره على اليمن في
المقابل هل حسبت هذه الاطراف امكانيه ان
يتوسع الصراع جراء هذه
العمليه نعم بالتاكيد هذهه المساله اخذت
بض الاعتبار لكن اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اخبرت الاطراف وان
ايران ربما قد تدفع
نتيجه للقيام باي عمليه تدخل كما حدث في
قتل سليماني عندما بدات ايران في احداث
عدد من المشاكل في كل من سوريا
والعراق طيب كان هناك اعلان قبل قليل معنا
على الجزيره من
قبل قيادي
في الجيش انصار الله الحوثيين قال بان كان
هناك احتكاك مع القوات الامريكيه
البريطانيه
و كذلك توجيه ضربات بالفعل الى البوارج
الامريكيه وهو ما تم الاشاره اليها رسميا
الان
في بيان بايدن وحتى في تصريحات رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك في تقديرك
هل ما حدث يوم التاسع من يناير تحديدا هو
الذي جعل هذه الضربه تكون خلال هذه
الفتره
اذا هذا الامر يجري لفتره من الزمن الكثير
من القاده من القياده الوسطى مثل مكنزي
كلهم كان يحثون بايدن بان يفعل شيئا اعلم
انهم التقوا بالرئيس الاحد الماضي لاتخاذ
هذا القرار وكان الرئيس يريد ان يتاكد من
ان لا تكون العمليه امريكيه فقط وانما ان
تشارك دول اخرى في هذه العمليه وفيما
يتعلق الامر بهذا الهجمات التي قام بها
الحوثيون كانت بمثابه القشه التي كسرت ظهر
البعير وبالتالي كان لابد من ان يكون هناك
رد وبالتالي كان هناك عدد من القاده الذين
دعموا ذلك بالاضافه الى مشرعين امريكيين
اخرين اتيت في
حديثك الى اشاره تتعلق ب عدد من الدول
وبان بايدن كان يريد ان يشارك عدد اكبر
منها في هذا الرد على جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين في اليمن هناك مثل ما تعرف تحالف
حارس الازدهار في عدد كبير من الدول في
تقديرك لماذا جاء الرد فقط من قبل
الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا هنا ك 30 دوله تشارك في هذا
المشروع مشروع حارس الازدهار
لكن الكثير من الدول هي تتوخى الحذر ولا
تريد ان تشارك في هذه الحرب في اطار هذا
النزاع الكبير ما بين اسرائيل
وحماس كنا نود ان ننتظر الى ان تلتحق بنا
دوله على الاقل واحده لوهي المملكه
المتحده التي هي حليف قوي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ويتمتع بالقدرات
المطلوبه وبالتالي هذا الامر استمر لفتره
طويله وعند انضمام دوله بدانا باتخاذ
القرار
والتحرك لاري كورب مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه السابق كبير الباحثين في مركز
التقدم الامريكي كنت معنا من واشنطن شكرا
جزيلا لك